um
have you been Dan is not a regular
friend because he's the last person I
dated before you know Jasmine meets up
with her ex Dane behind Gino's back and
I'm confused well she did say she tends
to go to extremes I reached from one
point you know to the other in seconds
Dane is out here giving Prince Charming
Vibes with a head full of hair meanwhile
Gino gives Uncle who goes nowhere
without his hat and we all know why
I don't know I think you're fantastic
any man would be lucky to have you this
Australian accent New Zealand what is it
I don't know but I like it Australian
okay
we'll get into why Jasmine is meeting up
with Dane now and why she says they
didn't work as a couple Plus in E.T
exclusive Jasmine shares Gino's first
reaction to meeting Mr Prince Charming
face to face he was actually intimidated
by him and we have to chat about tyrae
who thought he fell in love with a woman
named Carmella this goddess like cardi B
and Megan the stallion combined only to
learn Carmella had everything but uh
was that too much
cardi B Magna stallion
my bad it was a long hanging fruit
person you've been messaging with
is a man
thanks Harry you joined the wrong show
it's giving catfish let's get into it
okay 90 day fans fam it's melicia season
six of before the 90 days is starting
off strong this season's cast members
tug on your heartstrings they've been
through tons of adversity and now
they're inviting the drama of reality TV
into their lives
before we get into Jasmine and her ex
and tyrae and his catfish I want to
quickly chat with you about Amanda and
just a warning
her story is an emotional one but we
will not stay here for long Amanda is 31
years old and she's from Louisiana
earlier in the Year Amanda lost her
husband of eight years Jason to cancer
he was such a jokester
yeah he loved to make people laugh but
he also took great care of us
they had two kids together who seemed to
be the sweetest
box in the room yeah I think that would
be nice now Amanda's trying to adjust to
this major life change all while dating
again she's got a 26 year old boyfriend
named Roslyn from Romania he's the model
and a social media influencer
of course there is nothing wrong with
that occupation I just think what she's
looking for
he's not it I told the Ross van really
early on that I was a widow and he truly
has been someone that I can lean on and
he has talked me through some of my
worst days and I will say Amanda doesn't
come off as the type who is just ready
to move on from her husband but because
her husband is the only man she's been
with I think she's struggling to accept
life without one if we broke up it's
another man in my children's lives that
won't be there
she wants this Rosman guy to step into
this husband and father role and he's
told her without telling her but telling
her that's not what he's trying to do
well I love kids together
yeah but it's not only about playing
with them though you have to take care
of them like help them guide them no
listen I know it's important to be
around London but you know they are
missing their father and I never
can replace him you know but I want them
to see me like a friend
hmm
get to meet Rosman for the first time
soon but once all of this is said and
done hopefully she'll allow herself some
time to grieve it hasn't even been a
year yet so I could only imagine how
hard it is for her deep down I'm wishing
her and those adorable babies the best
all right moving on to tyrae getting
catfished on 90 Day Fiance it kind of
rhymed anyway let me give you a little
backstory on him my name is Tyree I'm 33
years old and I live in Modesto
California
care of her
I have a beautiful
Tyre is a teddy bear he's a good guy
I have two more sons and two daughters
the Terry helps me out more than any of
them give me a really good relationship
for fun tyrae likes to play the ukulele
I'm not a musician but I did pick up the
ukulele because I know it's that
everyone who plays it looks happy
and he also likes to get on Snapchat and
chat with who he thought was a woman
named Carmella which sounds like a name
a dude with makeup if they had to create
a woman
my girlfriend's name is Carmella and
she's 27 years old and she lives in
Barbados
likes Rihanna
[Music]
me and Carmella chat every day about
everything
from like random stuff to our plans for
the future we've been talking for almost
four years now wow four years Carmella
doesn't work right now no Carmella has
made it her job to scam you she's
extremely emotionally supportive
especially when my mom got sick so she
was there for me I really appreciated
that from her this is so messed up
what's wrong with people why would you
play somebody like that tyrae hasn't
told any of his loved ones about
Carmella because he doesn't want them to
judge him which tells me he knew
something was off they only talked on
Snapchat for four years and never video
chatted
come on now
we only communicate on Snapchat but we
do have you know naughty Snapchat
sessions now the question is where is
this catfish getting all these naughty
images from
overall this just shows you how much
tyrae is yearning for an intimate
connection before I go up to our videos
I do want to tell my family about
Carmella they have to know how deep I am
in love with her I want them to like
feel the love that I have for Carmella
tyrae has been overriding all reason
just to feel like he's in love I wish I
had a superpower to find people's
perfect match and bring them together at
the right time because I do believe
there is someone out there for everyone
and I know everybody has their own
lessons to learn but Tyrese seems so
sweet it sucks that he has to experience
this level of disappointment even though
is something he probably should have
caught on to a long time ago
we've learned some information about
Carmela that I need to let you know okay
after we talk about this if you decide
that you don't want to keep filming
let me know and also if you decide after
we talk that you don't want us to use
any of the footage
that we've already filmed that's okay
just let me know okay that's interesting
tyrae wanted us to see this at the end
of the episode the 90 day producers
birth the man's bubble the person you've
been
messaging with the last several years
is not the same woman in the pictures
and videos
like at all like
do y'all know who it is or like is it
they're not Neve we need Neve there's a
lot that we don't know but after you
gave us Carmela's number we reached out
and it took a while but eventually we
made contact
we talked to them for a bit and the
person admitted that they're not who
they've been telling you that they are
so the person you've been messaging with
is a man
wow
I'm sorry
oh
don't you just want to hug them and
y'all from the looks of the trailer his
storyline is not going to end here
this is an escort page this is her right
oh man well it's not the phone spot
Tyree
but I understand
take a break all right let's move on to
Gino and Jasmine I wanted to tell you
that I love you baby
Gina Was preparing to head back to
Panama to spend time with Jasmine she's
waiting on her K1 visa to get approved
so she can finally come to the U.S in
the meantime she talks Gino into paying
for a luxury apartment for her while she
waits for her paperwork to go through
Gino reluctantly says yes but come to
find out she learned about this luxury
apartment through her ex
good to see you yes you always have
yourself good oh Andy smells good the
power of cologne then the power of
cologne some good smelling cologne can
work wonders
I met Jan through a mutual friend like
five years ago it's a person you can
trust
um his handsome his fridge I mean he has
so many good qualities okay let's get
back to his character Jasmine she says
he's a person you can trust and as our
conversation goes on you start to see
he's also really present and a good
listener I have good news tell me
because
I just smoke into your birthday
fantastic I'm excited we're going to be
neighbors right that'll be good yeah we
can cook together yeah we can teach me
to cook Now Jasmine I'm gonna tell you
right now do not set yourself up by
cooking with that man
don't do it and we know if Geno even
tried to utter those words out of his
mouth why did you do it her response
would be explosive and speaking of Gino
Jasmine tells Dane he's coming to town
and Dane's surprised to learn that they
will all three be neighbors
so will it be awkward you know if I bump
into him there well according to Jasmine
when Gino finally does bump into him
he feels some type of way during my
conversation with her she said Gino
never talks bad about anyone but he had
a lot to say about Dane he was like oh I
don't know how you like this guy oh blue
eyes like oh come on it was like yeah
long hair I don't like his hair I was
like you're crazy he looks like a doll
and then he went there and look on his
lips he has no lips and I look at Dino
and like you literally have the same
freaking lips
for the first time you know was saying
this kind of nasty things about a person
I was kind of oh that was cute for me I
know that's crazy but I was like oh that
is super cute because he was actually
intimidated by him I would love to see
Gino's physical reaction to meeting Dame
I could see the look on his face now
Jasmine goes on to explain the reason
why she and Dane didn't work out which
is that he was too nice
with Dan if it was so perfect he's such
a gentleman no fights no arguments no
nothing I got bored and I ran away I
don't get it send me a handsome man with
a kind heart who is honest and treats me
like a queen plus he's well off and he
smells good with a cute little accent
something is not adding up here Jasmine
but
then again Some people prefer toxic
relationships because the chaos feels
normal to them or it's exciting I need
someone that is gonna give me that fire
you know she wants somebody who's going
to give her a headache meanwhile I'm
over here like if you don't add to my
piece you're out Jasmine goes on to tell
Dane about the pain Gino has caused her
in the past specifically when he sent
topless photos of her to his ex who
allegedly sent those photos to the
school where Jasmine worked as a teacher
resulting in her getting fired how did
you get through it I haven't I still
like have trusting issues yeah we're
arguing all the time but I'm devoted
babe when I love someone
I I love her
I don't mean this book's too bad tuna
because I don't know him but
you don't want to kind of force anything
I don't think like unless you're going
to spend your life together that's a
long time
I don't know I think you're fantastic
any man would be lucky to have you
so
you know don't settle for something
that's not up to what you want for
yourself
good advice I know we talked about
Gino's reaction to meeting Dane but I
can't wait to see Dane's reaction to
meeting Gino
that's going to be interesting all right
when it comes to the rest of the season
Gino and Jasmine look like they are in
for a wild ride you've been a bad bad
girl bad girl you will do as I say
[Music]
that I'm so broken be honest you will be
happier without me
oh
oh all right 90 day fans fam make sure
you stick with ET because we are
covering it all I will see you next time
[Music]